your Majesty's excellencies ladies and
gentlemen the Norwegian Nobel Committee
has decided to award the Nobel Peace
Prize for 2010 to live shabu for its
long and non violent struggle for
fundamental rights in China the
Norwegian Nobel Committee has long
believed that there is a close
connection between human rights and
peace such rights are a prerequisite for
the fraternity between nations of which
Alfred Nobel wrote in his will this was
the first paragraph of the committee's
announcement on the AIDS or toddler this
year we regret that the laureate is not
present he is in isolation in a prison
in northeast China nor can the low rates
wife lyosha or his closest relatives be
with us no medal or diploma will
therefore be presented here today this
fact alone shows that the award both
necessary and appropriate we
congratulate Li you trouble with this
year's Peace Prize
there have been a number of previous
occasions when the laureate has not has
been prevented from attending this has
in fact been the case with several
awards which in the light of history had
proven to be most significant and
honorable even when the laureate has
come he or she has been severely
condemned by the authorities of his or
her own country there was a great deal
of trouble in 1935 when the committee
gave the award to cult on ucs kill
Hitler was furious and prohibited all
Germans from accepting any Nobel Prize
King Haakon did not attend and the
ceremony and the committee was split
OCSE did not come to Oslo and died a
year later there was considerable
outrage in Moscow when Andrei Sakharov
received his prize in 1975 he too was
prevented from receiving the abroad in
person he sent his wife the same thing
happened when like Valentine in 1983 the
Burmese authorities they're furious when
unpunctual she received the Peace Prize
in 1991
once again the low rate could not come
to Oslo in 2003 fearing a body received
the Nobel Peace Prize
she came merge could be said or the
reaction of the Iranian authorities but
the Iranian ambassador did in fact
attend the ceremony the Novation Nobel
Committee has given for prices to South
Africa all the lower rates came to Oslo
but the awards to Albert the Thule in
1960 and to Desmond Tutu in 1984
provoked great outrage in the apartheid
regime in South Africa before the
applause broke out thanks to the awards
to Nelson Mandela and Frederik de Klerk
in
denied three the point of these awards
has of course never been to offend
anyone the Nobel committees intention
has been to say something about the
relationship between human rights
democracy and peace and it has been
important to remind the world that the
rights vide so widely enjoyed today were
fought and won by persons who took great
risks they did solve for others for all
of us this is widely usable disturbs
over support today
although none of the committee's members
have ever met live we feel that they
know him we have studied him closely
over a long period of time Lee was born
on the 28th of December 1955 in function
in China's Jilin province they took a
bachelor's degree in literature a
trillion University at a master's degree
and PhD at Beijing Normal University
very also taught stays abroad included
visits to Oslo Hawaii and Columbia
University in New York in 1989 he
returned home to take part in the
dawning democracy movement on the 2nd of
June he and some friends started a
hunger strike on tiannamen square to
protest against the state of emergency
that had been declared they issued a
six-point democratic manifesto written
by Lee you for posing dictatorship and
in favor of democracy the you was
opposed to any physical struggle against
the authorities on the part of the
students he tried to find a peaceful
solution to the tension between the
students and the government non-violence
was already figuring prominently in his
message on the 4th of June he and his
friends tried to prevent a clash between
the army and the students he was only
partially successful many lives were
lost
most of them outside Tiananmen Square
ryu has told his wife that he would like
this year's Peace Prize to be dedicated
to the lost souls from the ports of doom
as he put it it is indeed a pleasure for
us to fulfill his wish
leave has said that the greatness of
non-violence resistance is that even as
man is faced with forceful tyranny and
resulting suffering the victim responds
to hate with low to prejudice with
tolerance to arrogance with humility to
humiliation with dignity and to violence
with reason the unarmed man became a
turning point in the u.s. life in 1996
live was sentenced to three years in
labor camp for so-called rumor rumor
mongering and slander it was president
of the independent Chinese pen Center
from 2003 to 2007 vu has written nearly
800 essays 499 of them since night 2005
at 5:00 he was one of the chief
architects behind charter oh wait which
was made known on the 10th of December
2008 which was in the words of the
preamble of the document on the occasion
of the 100th anniversary of China's
first constitution the 60th anniversary
of the promulgation of the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights the 30th
anniversary of the birth of the of the
democracy wall and the tenth anniversary
of the Chinese government's signature of
the International Covenant on Civil and
Political Rights Charter or eight
defends fundamental human rights and has
in due course been signed by several
thousand persons balls in China itself
and abroad on the 25th of December 2009
Liam was sentenced to 11 years in prison
and two years lost of political rights
for in the words of the sentence
incitement to the overthrow of the state
power and socialist
and the People's Democratic dictatorship
Ryu was has constant constantly claimed
that the sentence violates both China's
own Constitution and fundamental rights
there are many dissidents in China and
their opinions differ on many points the
severe punishment imposed on the you
made him more than a central spokesman
for human rights practically overnight
he became the very symbol both in China
and internationally of the non-violent
struggle for such rights in China we can
say that Li you reminds us of Nelson
Mandela your Majesty's ladies and
gentlemen during the Cold War the
connection between peace and human
rights were disputed since the end of
the Cold War however peace researchers
and political scientists have almost
without exception and the line have
closed those connections are this is
allegedly one of the most robust
findings they have arrived at
democracy's may go to war against
dictatorship and AB certainly waged
colonial wars but there is apparently
not a single example of a democracy
having gone to war against another
democracy so the deeper fraternity
between nations which Alfred Nobel
mentions in his will and which is a
prerequisite for real peace can hardly
be created without human rights and
democracy your Majesties
there are scarcely an examples in world
history or a great power achieving such
rapid growth or such a long period of
time as China since 1978 year by year
decade after decade
the country's growth rate has stood at
10 percent or more a few years ago the
countries of wit was greater than
Germany's this year it exceeded Japan's
China has achieved the world's sixth
second-largest gross national product
the United States national product is
still three times greater than China's
but while China is continuing its
advance the United States is in serious
difficulties so economic success has
lifted several hundred million Chinese
of the poverty for the reduction in the
number of poor people in the world China
must be given the main credit
we all appreciate this and the commend
and congratulate China for these
extraordinary achievements
and therefore we can to a certain degree
say that China with its 1.3 billion
people is carrying mankind's fate on its
shoulders if the country proves capable
of developing a social market economy
with full civil rights this will have a
huge favorable impact on the world if
not there is a danger of sort of an
economic crisis arising in the country
with negative consequences for us all
and here we have arrived at a very logic
of this year's price historical
experience gives us reason to believe
that continuing rapid economic growth
presupposes opportunities for free
speech free research precinct and free
debate and moreover without freedom of
expression corruption the abuse of power
and miss rule will develop every power
system must be counter balanced by
popularly elected control free media and
right of individual citizens to
criticize more or less of all terian
states may have long periods of rapid
economic growth but it is no coincidence
that nearly all the richest countries in
the world are democratic because
democracy mobilizes new human and
technological resources China's new
status entails increased responsibility
China must be prepared for criticism and
regard it as positive as an opportunity
for improvement this must be the case
wherever there is great power we have
all formed opinions on the role of the
United States through the years friends
and allies criticize the country
for the before the vietnam war and the
lack of civil rights for the colored
people many Americans were opposed to
the award of the Nobel Peace Prize to
dr. Martin Luther King in 1964 looking
back we can see that the United States
grew stronger many other American people
obtained their rights China too will
grow stronger if his people is being
granted civil rights
many will ask whether China's weakness
for all the strengths the country is
currently showing is not manifested in
the need to imprison a man for 11 years
merely for expressing his opinions on
how his country should be governed this
weakness finds clear expression in the
sentence on the you where it is
underlined as especially serious that he
spread these opinions on the Internet
the doors to fear technological advances
have every reason to fear the future
information technology cannot be
abolished it will continue to open
societies as the President of the
Russian Federation Dmitry media have put
it in an address to the State Duma and I
quote the new information technology
gives us an opportunity to be connected
with the world the world and society are
growing more open even if the ruling
class does not like it no doubt medieval
had the fate of the Soviet Union in mind
compulsory uniformity and control of
thought prevented the country from
participating in the technological
revolution which took place in the 1970s
and 1980s the system broke down the
country could have stood to gain a great
deal more from entering into a dialogue
at an early stage with people like
Andrei Sakharov your Majesties ladies
and gentlemen today's world order is the
consequence of the two horrible wars in
a 20th century the world had to move
from in from nationalism towards
internationalism by establishing the
united nation and adopting the universal
declaration of human
today therefore neither the nation-state
nor a majority bid in a nation-state
has unlimited power human rights limit
what the nation-state and the majority
in a nation-state can do this must apply
to all states that are members of the
United Nations and you have acceded to
the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights
China has signed and even ratified
several of the UN's and Aiello's major
international conventions and on human
rights it is interesting that China has
accepted the supranational conflict
resolving mechanism of the World Trade
Organization China's own Constitution
upholds fundamental human rights article
35 of the country's constitution thus
lays down the citizens of the People's
Republic of China enjoy freedom of
speech of the press or assembly of
association or procession and on
demonstration article 41 begins by
stating that citizens have the right to
criticise and make suggestions regarding
and state organ or functionary Li Yue
has only exercised his civil rights he
has not done anything wrong he must be
released
ladies and gentlemen in the past 100 to
150 years human rights a democracy have
gained an ever stronger position in the
world and with them peace
this can be clearly seen in Europe we
saw many wars were fought and whose
colonial powers started so many wars
around the world Europe is today on the
whole a continental peace decolonization
after the Second World War
together and gave a number of countries
first in Asia and then in Africa the
chance to govern themselves with respect
for basic human rights with India in the
lead many of them seized the opportunity
of the latest decades we have seen
democracy has consolidated his position
in that America and essentially Eastern
Europe many countries in the Muslim part
of the world are trading the same parts
Turkey Indonesia Malaysia several other
countries are in the process of opening
up their political systems the human
rights activists in China are defenders
of the international order and the main
trends in the global community viewed in
that light they are not dissidents they
represent the world's common values and
standards
Liew denies that criticism of the
communist party is the same as offending
China and the Chinese people he argues
that even if the Communist Party is the
ruling party
it cannot be equated with the country
let alone with the nation and his
culture changes in China can take time a
very long time political reforms should
as leo says be gradual peaceful orderly
and controlled china has in his words
had enough of attempts at revolutionary
change they can only lead to chaos but
as Li also writes an enormous
transformation towards pluralism in
society has already taken place and
official Authority is no longer able to
truly control the whole society however
strong the power of the regime may
appear to be every single individual
must do his best to live in his words an
honest life with dignity the answer from
the Chinese authorities is to claim that
this year's Peace Prize humiliate China
and to give very derogatory descriptions
of the history solves many similar
examples of political leaders playing on
nationalist feelings and attempting to
demonize holders or contrary opinions
there soon become foreign agents this
has sometimes happened in the name of
democracy and freedom but almost always
with a tragic outcome we recognize for
instance this in the rhetoric of the
struggle against terrorism you are
either for me or against me search and
democratic methods as torture and
imprisonment without sentence have been
used in the name of freedom this has led
to more polarization of the world and
harmed the fight against terrorists
reusable is an optimist
this part is many years in prison in his
clothing appealed to the court on the
23rd of December 2009 he said I filled
with optimism look forward to the advent
of a future pre-final for there is no
force that can put an end to the human
quest for freedom and China will in the
end become a nation ruled by law the
human rights we are supreme
your Majesty's excellencies the ladies
and gentlemen Isaac Newton once said if
I have seen further it is by standing on
the shoulders of giants when we are able
to look ahead today it is because we are
standing on the shoulders of the many
men and women who over the years often
at great risk has stood up for what they
believed in and thus made over freedom
possible and therefore while some are
only looking to the commercial interests
some political leaders only focusing
exclusively on the other short-term
national interest and others remaining
totally indifferent the no vision Nobel
Committee has once again chosen to
support those who fight for us all
we congratulate lyucia bow on the Nobel
Peace Prize for 2010 his views will in
the long run strengthens China we extend
to him and to China our very best wishes
for the years ahead thank you very much
you're my city's excellencies ladies and
gentlemen it has not been possible as we
know for live shabu or any of his close
relatives to come to Oslo to receive the
Nobel medal and diploma at this stage in
the ceremony will be normally handover
the medal and the diploma I place them
in the empty chair held by new shabu
mr. Renick the middle defense is real
in his face
you